today's lecture will be about the end
games of Fabiana Cara Juana for obvious
reasons
does anybody know what's the obvious
reason you know no come on what's what's
his score against me
you know loses all of his games when
he's playing me now why are we talking
about Fabiana Cara Wanda today anybody
did you have a real answer what is it
no he's not second in the world either
he used to be anyone nobody knows my
comer knows now okay you can tell Mike
yeah oh yeah yeah
Fabiana Cara Juan it is transferring his
Federation from Italy to the US she'll
be playing in the US Championship losing
me there the Olympiad where I'll be
coaching him and the world team
championship probably watching from afar
well I won't be coaching him either so
the US team will be a little bit
stronger so I thought I would since it's
an end game lecture I thought I would
talk about Fabiano's best end games and
we'll start with one where he beats the
world's best player and world champion
Magnus Carlsen now as you can tell from
this position when opening did this
start out as anyone yes they're very
close yes that's less clothes actually
Italians close it times actually closer
yes now you're going crazy over there
all right the correct answer obviously
is the Berlin there's a Berlin end game
I mean Karan one is playing Carlston
they could both be playing the Berlin
because they both play with white and
black now this has gone quite well for
white because first of all whites upon a
head so that's pretty good usually black
has doubled pawns on the queenside but
they're gone now
white has a beautiful knight on d5 white
has four to three on the Kings side this
is very
or if you were here last week for my
lecture where I dressed up as Alejandra
Ramirez you'll remember I talked a lot
about kappa blanka and kappa blanka said
you should always advance your pawns on
this side you have a majority if you cut
the board in half you'll see on the
kingside White has four pawns 2/3 and
they have an equal number of pawns on
the Queen side which is typical in this
opening so white is going to try to
advance his King side pawns and black as
you can see is very passive now black
has one advantage that grandmasters in
particular like quite a bit you has the
bishop pair unfortunately that Bishop
Bunji it's pretty weak so are do you
think that Bishop on Diaz could inherit
the earth
now a good answer well put okay so
Fabiano's white and I like this game for
a couple reasons for Fabiano's sake one
is he's beating Carlsen the other is
he's playing in the vu Garga Shema
memorial this was the first one they
also had won this year one of our
world's top players who died at a young
age so have the Morial tournament form
is very nice okay so black played b5
because black doesn't want to sit around
and lose black wants to get counter play
black wants to open the position so the
bishops can have their say fortunately
after the trade on b5 you'll notice
these pawns are what do we call them
Arjen isolated pawns right so they're
sort of weak okay as Meredith discovered
today isolated pawns not so good okay so
these pawns are by themselves on the
other hand we've improved our Bishop
somewhat because we don't have a pawn
blocking it if the game gets really open
the bishops will have their say 93 which
prevents more trades in the endgame when
you're winning you want to have as many
pawns as possible if you have six pawns
to five it's likely you'll win if you
have two pawns to one then it's very
hard to win because often what the other
side can do is sacrifice a piece
your only remaining pawn and you'll have
rook and Knight against rook or rook and
Bishop versus rook which is a
theoretical draw but there's a lot of
puns on the board you have a better
chance of making a queen so after 93 the
Knights protecting the c-4 square making
it hard to play c4 as we all know c4 is
explosive of course and you get that
joke Arjen
no okay and also the knight is
protecting the Kings side so it's
helping us move our King side pawns
forward with so many arrows Black is in
trouble
okay so Ricky six blocking the e pawn
maybe we're going to swing over here and
take the a pawn
there's no way Carolina's going to see
that coming f4 advancing on this side
with the majority wreck a6 attacking a -
I wonder if you saw it Rick G - now a
lot of lower rated players love to move
pawns if they can move upon they can
especially wouldn't attack something but
that actually is very weakening the more
forward you move the pawns the more
likely you're going to take them white
doesn't want to move his Queen side
funds forward he doesn't have an
advantage over there that's two against
two
he wants to move his King side pawns
forward because he has more pawns of his
opponent which pawn would become quite
weak if white plays a4 let's call in a
random person Julian the b3 pawn which
would no longer have any defense and he
would be envious of the a4 pawn which
would be embarrassed on a for this
because of the colors okay Joe didn't
work out too well but its audience is a
little slow today
okay I'm not in the South anymore or am
i seamless alright so he played rook to
d2 and now a2 is protected and cannot be
attacked again b3 is protected the
knight on e3 is stopping the advance c4
so it's hard for black to do anything
except to wait to lose they hate to do
that
h5 put it in H right Julian also as I
said earlier in the lecture
but you forgot because it was like two
minutes ago I'm not talking to you
you're very intelligent audience some of
people at home you lazy people not even
coming to the Chess Club you look at the
lecture just sitting on your couch
eating that terrible food drinking your
sugary drinks and watching this great
lecture instead of coming to the club at
the kingside diner and having some great
food right my comer exactly
all right so h5 black wants to trade off
all the pawns then it'll be a draw
the fewer pawns on the board the greater
chances of success for a draw takes on
h5 now Magnus Carlsen called Guinness
and said did I break the world's record
for isolated pawns okay
unfortunately he called the wrong
Guinness and he got a case of beer so it
worked out okay hi so now Knight f5 or
as I like to say knife f5 because of the
Greek Grandmaster you only heard of one
of them you've only heard of one Greek
grandmaster ever heard of any of them
anybody know there's about fifteen
regram there so she only heard of one of
them what's that I said Greek if it ends
in itch that's you know Serbian Croatian
Yugoslavia okay the correct answer
obviously is Vasilyev Petronius and when
I was in Moscow in 1984 I think I saw
origin there were you there you were
there right argent
Vasily as Cutrone yes it wasn't a
grandmaster at the time he said Ben it's
not Knight f5 its knife f5 now anybody
in the audience who has an advanced
degree in hyperbolic topology could tell
you white has a very obvious threat here
anyone what's why it's obvious threat
yes as my color would say argent dad
Knight d6 check okay and then for key
not only this but as all my kids would
say also the pawn also good
you [ __ ] upon also hey that Forks the
king and queen what about that pun
alright I hear that a lot
alright so notice how whites up the
knife from d5 a great square and put on
another good square f5 okay so we have
to stop that d6 check rook g6 check
Knight d6 would be double check but was
not played King h2 again most people
like to go sideways and forwards they
don't like to go back but in this
instance White's goal is to make his
King safe if the King goes to f3 black
has bishop c6 check the King could get
in trouble
h2 is very safe there's no way that
black can attack that King and now
White's 3096 check again bishop c6 now
Knight d6 check doesn't win the bishop
on b5 because it's no longer there 96
anyway King to be a f5 again White's
advancing the majority now most of you
would be greedy as would I
and take this pawn on f7 why didn't it's
a new move that's not good no it's
supposed to say like you really it's so
I thought I would still do that
Wow I was going to say Bishop g3 but I'm
pushing the arrow and I'm not getting
anything okay so they're suggesting that
I feel after Bishop h4 black head
threats like Bishop g3 check attacking
all of white stuff that seems sort of
annoying okay so instead white plate f5
because getting a queen is good rook GA
f6 and now the bishop on GA once again
isn't very good and we stop the ideas of
black getting active most people are
very greedy they want to take a lot of
pawns Cara Wan is like I'm up upon I
have a great night my opponent has four
isolated pawns all I have to do is stop
counter play blacks counter play Bishop
h4 Bishop g3 check and white is getting
attacked it always stops hanging f6 sort
of prevents that this should be six
trying to activate the bishop the other
way maybe he'll play c4 bishop g1 mate
very likely unless unless Caruana stops
it 9 c4
I guess that stops it okay so - one
minute game you know you jump over your
pawn now that doesn't work alright rook
e8 9 to d6 why did white played 96 let's
call it a random person Julian always
always always repeat now we're talking
alright now he took on f7 he's not
afraid of getting needed c4 most people
would take on c4 it still didn't it
didn't do it very suspicious bishop g1
with advantage because the game is over
alright let's see yeah it's not do I
don't know what it's doing taxing crazy
over here okay so why gave his King
extra lift even though he's moving to
the US he still like Germany a little
bit h4 now his king can go to h3 so
bishop g1 check doesn't work it's
checked so that's pretty good
this is the beginner breakdown class
Bishop g1 check for sure got ribbon
check all right rook G for tacking the H
pawn ISA --xs
two queens is better than one if you saw
the movie contact two rocket ships okay
II 6 Bishop e3 again Black's not
interested in taking pawns he's going to
lose he wants to check make the White
King Bishop e3 attacking the rook Bishop
f4 check with some minor threats if I
was white I would play a solutions of
year I actually don't know what he
played by play there should be five
check he might not season check all
right I got one right no wonder I beat
him real easily man okay
man I should I should play for the u.s.
I mean I got to call Italy immediately
all right King a rugby a check
I predict king b7 yes all right hey
could have resigned come on Bishop g3
stopping rook g2 check and stopping rook
takes h4 so White's plan has come to
fruition he was trying to advance his
majority he did a pretty good job blacks
trying to get counter play with the two
bishops
but White has good defense bishop on g3
basically stops everything so man those
pawns look pretty good on e6 and f6 c3
rook check once again I predict King a
sex rook c8 if the bishop moves rook
takes c3 looks good bishop d5 if you
play king to b7
it seems like I have a lot of good moves
I could play rook c7 Shaq or Knight d6
check that looks terrible
so he played Bishop g5 that seems like a
good idea taking us I agree with that
rook takes c3 Bishop to d4 Bishop takes
6
you could play rook c6 check you could
play 98 and both bishops are attacked
I'm guessing Rick c6 check okay he
played Bishop to d4 attacking the rook
rook there rook to e4 what d2 again
blacks trying to attack the white king
with the rook and two bishops no counter
play rook G to rook takes c6 if rook
takes Bishop then rookie to check you
know it's now it's new variation what's
going on
what okay then we'll check and then some
kind of you know like I probably go here
expecting Bishop takes Knight and then
oh hey when that happens I mean when I'm
black I like it that what I'm white yeah
that would be fine okay so instead
Caruana played Knight to g5 and you'll
notice black has a lot of pieces
attacked a few too many so normally I
would predict rook takes f6 but I
predict resigns okay I got one right
yeah Knight g5 so black eventually
stopped White's pawns but lost to Bishop
as a result that was a very nice endgame
because not only did he beat Carlsen but
he got his pawn majority on the Kings
side going without allowing black too
much counter play although that was a
lot of counter play but he just stopped
at all
Karlsson tried hard but in the end he
failed miserably
the lesson is don't try right Kyle
alright right now I'll try to go to the
next game so let's take a 20-minute
break now because I don't know you told
me to actually this out that'll work
perfectly no okay now what do I do click
this how'd that work that worked pretty
well okay now the gawking rabble are
always telling me
obviously colored bishops is a draw as a
car in Mecca and we would say frankly
ridiculous okay
probably he would say that about Caruana
playing for the u.s. that's a different
lecture okay so this
we have opposite colored bishops Cara
Juana is white against the tallest
player that I've that I beaten maybe
yeah I think so he wasn't so tall when I
beat him now
Luca van Whaley okay and he's been to
the Chess Club before but it was much
funny when he was detained at JFK and
sent back home that was funnier not for
him okay so here white is a pawn ahead
obviously collar bishops would often be
a draw but now with rooks on the board
okay so car one is white rook b8
attacking the pawn like Cara Wan is not
going to see that this is a beginner
breakdown this is real life rugby 1 and
there's a very famous thing which you
all know so I just want to say it now
rooks go behind pass pawns that when the
pawns advance the rook has more scope
and this rook has no listerine even
though it's green lucky was green
otherwise that truck wouldn't it made
sense okay Bishop to d2 making B for not
so good Bishop to e2 attacking the weak
pawn so white wants to win lots of pawns
and then play on both sides of the board
advancing his pawns because that be
pawns not going anywhere now black has
two problems in this ending other than
the fact these down upon the G pawn is
weak and potentially the d6 pawn is weak
if I can attack that White's only
problem is as e4 pawn Black's going to
try to attack that I assume threat b4 I
assumed right Bishop c4 and one of the
things you're going to see in this
lecture which isn't very exciting for
you although I enjoy it this is my
lecture is Cara Wan is very patient okay
he doesn't want to win in two moves
doesn't want to win in four moves he
wants to put you to sleep
so if my lunch doesn't put you to sleep
his play well so we got you we got you
one way or the other
Cara Juana very patient slowly
his advantages not one of the strong
suits of Luca Vaughn Whaley he likes to
mix it up play complicated chesa
confuses opponent Caruana wants to play
8090 move games because if you play 90
moves you might make one mistake not my
comer but some of you you play 90 moves
you might make some errors so the longer
the game goes the more mistakes he
thinks his opponents going to make and
he's not in a hurry because black can't
make any threats
once the bishops on c4 the rook on b4 is
not very good and there's nothing really
for blacks to attack White's going to
slowly build its position now that the
bishop is on c4 defending the pawn on b3
this rook can run around and start
attacking things f5 again blacks not
very patient eat xf 5 where Julian go is
he here he ran away crying lectures to
hard form one of my rules which I taught
on my private students if your opponent
plays f5 you'd play eat akes f5 it's one
of my rules here it's sort of simple
again G four pawns pretty weak King f6
the rook is coming to take on d6 or g4
and he says now you're not going to do
that
he plays rook to b8 for two reasons one
is he stops where K eight more
importantly he wants his Bishop to go to
be for defending this pawn later we're
going to go to c5 and put pressure that
the Siobhan Dietz she wasn't very good
on b4 c5 it defends the d6 pawn rook a6
Bishop b4 as explained Bishop to d3
defending his pawn now if you played
Bishop to d3 earlier then the rook would
take so now that the ships on b4 we have
time the ship c5 discovered attack on
the pawn bishop c2 now we've gone from
one pawn ahead to two pawns ahead and y
can try to win that Jeep on with
something like rook to a4
efore again not very patient black is
playing very actively he's trying to
trade pawns off activate his pieces and
hope that with obviously colored bishops
even if he's down upon hurt so he has
good drawing chances he doesn't want to
wait around to lose he wants to play
actively rook a for again don't be
greedy and take this then your b3 pawn
is hanging and now well I can get good
counter play on f0 instead Rick the rook
on a6 isn't doing anything now rook goes
to a for e3 the idea of e4 takes takes
and now it's very hard to defend g4
black spawns are disappearing defends g4
and now a very nice smooth with a double
threat who can find it White has a fork
it attacks a piece and a square that he
wants to go to yes Kyle rookie for
tagging the bishop and I want to play
rook e6 check saves the bishop defending
his pawn b4 get your bishop outta there
so I can check and take your deep on ok
and white went from one pawn ahead to
three pawns ahead okay does anybody know
what time it is time to resign but if
I'm Willy doesn't resign he's a bitter
ender like me okay never resigned fight
bishop be a rook g6 if the rook goes
somewhere else we can take the pawn on
g3 so well if white like doesn't trade
rooks and moves his rook away he's going
to lose his g4 pawn so we're going to
get to this ending where White has a lot
of extra pawns and d6 is nothing that
sneeze at we're threatening Bishop c4
check okay now some of you are like wait
why can't I play rook da that looks
pretty safe after Bishop here check you
might get checkmated for example check
a or kingi he loses probably for more
than one reason but I'll play the reason
that I see I can't go there and I think
I'm winning a rook right looks like you
can't defend your rook anymore okay so
d6 was a great move it threatens Bishop
c4 winning the rook and it threatens
Bishop c4 mating you so black is forced
to trade rooks and White has three
passed pawns it's hard to stop them all
and actually they get to a theoretical
endgame you can't take the bishop
because of g7 and why it's going to
Queen and he gets this theoretical
ending with two pawns again zero and we
have a rule for this if the pawns are
very close together it's a draw here the
pawns are really far apart that's
actually good because the King and
Bishop have to stay on one of the pawns
and the white King just comes over if
the pawns are next to each other that we
can blockade for example if this was
here this would be an easy draw there's
nothing I can do surprisingly even if
the pawns run f4 and g4 right next to
each other it's still a draw when
they're close together it's a draw when
they're really far apart blacks King and
Bishop can't go both directions he has
to keep this King stopping one the
bishop stopping the other where do you
think the white king goes to the black
king or two the black bishop the black
bishop because my king can't go next to
your King lets you cheat a lot okay so
that's what he does again you can't play
King takes bishop because I queen and
the King walks to the bishop and what if
I'm really do here he resigned because
I'm going to play King here I'm going to
push my pawn you're going to sacrifice
your bishop for my pawn and all the
Bishop and pawn against nothing so I
like that endgame because a lot of
people are under the misconception when
it's obviously colored bishops it's
always a draw
okay now you've heard the famous rule
all rook and pawn endings are drawn
which is the opposite of my rule they're
all winning so G if it's G and HS to
draw F and G it's a draw yeah because
the bishop can always sacrifice for the
two pawns if you set up the right
position this is pretty funny this was a
Marshall
this is Carwin Aronian from zurich last
year and they trade it to this position
normally in the marshall black's upon
down and here it's equal material so you
would think it's an easy draw black has
the two bishops black's not down upon
but white has several advantages one is
the greatest bishop ever and the other
is these pawns are both isolated the
third advantage is my rook is really
great I have a lot of good squares to go
to threatening your pawns and your
bishops
so because why does the better pawn
structure why does the better rook
White's Bishop is on d4 he actually has
an advantage and one of the reasons that
black lost this game is he thought this
would be a relatively easy draw he's
playing the marshal down upon he wins
his pawn back as the two bishops he's
like what's the problem well he soon
finds out what the problem is
rook a six most of you see the threat
some of you are like why doesn't he play
pawn takes rook that's what you were
thinking at home admit it admit it
yep and somebody's like oh my god I was
thinking that now the pawns Oh move
backwards okay Bishop to e7 very
suspicious but safe 9 - f 1 why did ye
play Knight to f1 reroute to e3 putting
pressure on the pawn on d5 b4 now if you
remember the previous game and you don't
I said when you're in trouble you trade
all the pawns and nobody can beat you
there's no puns on the board he's not
going to win with a rook and Knight
against the rook so B for trading pawns
Bishop to d3 how many of you want to
take this pawn it's free
yeah gets a noisier in here a fuels
going to break out Knight takes d5 check
winning the night yeah better Wow Bishop
takes rook yeah I can't see that that's
too hard
this should be for check now we're
talking okay so my comers suggest the
improvement Bishop takes rook so Cara
wanna plays rook a5 attacking the D pawn
again and they trade Bishop to d8
attacking the rook rook takes d5 falls
into the same trick Bishop b4 check
plays rook to e8 f6
what's wrong with that move anyone never
play up six exactly
okay so then I'll teach Aronian to play
chess again Knight takes d5 loses except
now I'm right the ship you for track I
tell my students you shouldn't keep your
King on the same color as your
opponent's Bishop problem is by it's got
two bishops so that's hard to do you
going to sort of play around the squares
in the middle you like you're playing go
you don't know you know I'm talking
about
yeah the otherwise the bishop is going
to check you now here the white king is
obviously safer on a dark square for the
simple reason that white has a dark
squared bishop so that can block a lot
of the checks okay you played f3 because
black played f6 so they like they hate
my lecture
okay that's auspi should be for check
prepares King f2 the d5 pawn is a goner
it's hard to see that in the long run
Bishop e7 trading rooks White's like no
I don't trade white knows the very
important rule never train okay and also
if we trade trade trade trade will be a
draw and most importantly if you don't
believe in my crazy rules
then sometimes I don't but I usually do
this is the greatest trick ever it's on
the open file attacking everything and
it's efore excellent this Rick just
sitting on he ate the whole game that's
like a might calm or Bishop unsee it
they can't move it's always been on he
ate Rick a7 my tricks on the seventh
rank that's exactly where I want it
Bishop to d6 rook d7 Bishop e3 hiding
and finally he wins the pawn it's not so
easy to win how are we get a queen RC
pawn I'll take a long time and black has
a lot of pieces that will stop it so
it's still tough to win King to g8
probably white doesn't want to have
black have the two bishops so if Y could
play like Bishop c5 check and trade
bishops it'll be easier to win if flex
always having is two bishops that's not
so simple so King GA h4 gaining space on
the King side Bishop c1 threatening the
knight Knight g4 tax the rook tax the
bishop tax the night and now finally
black made what the first rook moving
the whole endgame g4 White's gaining
space on the Kings side it's hard to
Queen his upon right now and again
Cara Juan is not in a hurry he wants to
gain space for two reasons it's good to
gain space and also for his King safety
if black starts attacking like in the
last game we saw with Carlsen White King
needs some squares to go to rook a to
King g3 there's a square to go to my
comer vision f4 double question mark now
I'm teasing
yeah well this [ __ ] man Bishop Bishop f4
is what I would have played so I agree
normally I would say Knight d3 but I'm
sort of worried about rook a to check
maybe I shouldn't because of bishop f2
but I'm still worried Bishop f4 to me is
the obvious move does
why play G for you want your Bishop on
f4 well exactly that's why you're going
to play this thing feel Cup and not this
Aronian guy how has he done the last two
Singh field kubbs not very well
all right so rook a to King g3 rook back
to a six white slowly improves this
position white really wants to trade
bishops if black has the two bishops he
can create a lot of threats like we saw
in the Carlson game but now he's forced
to trade bishops the bishop has nowhere
to go
now White's King is perfectly safe
there's no way blacks going to attack
and now that the bishop here is gone
we're ready to advance our pawn okay and
actually I would say blacks King is in a
little trouble because of this work on
the seventh ranked ok stopping c4 and
White's just slowly improving his
position and now c4 very tricky tactical
move confusing the audience if Bishop
takes c4 Knight b7 attacking the rook
attacking the bishop and by the way I
got Knight d6 check just in case so not
good for black okay probably Aronian
overlook c4 thinking he had the pawn
stopped Bishop to a a a fantastic square
for the Bishop did you want to suggest
another move no okay Bishop a8 rook
check 96 White's witting on both sides
of the board White has a better King
a better rook a better night I mean a
better mind your piece and he's a pawn
ahead now we have a direct attack on the
g7 pawn very easy to stop rook a3
threatening rook f3 checkmate
man that Rodian stuff just when you
think you had them okay and Caruana
didn't see the maid so he resigned no he
played rook check
you silly King h8 and now King f5 the
King goes to g6 f7 h6 both sides are
getting needed but mainly black is
White's King is escaping rook g6 winning
all of blacks for being pawns hate when
that happens
okay and black has no pawns rook f3
check Knight f4 remove the king black
kid with the g4 pawn which I'm sure it's
still winning for white but why give the
pawn away Bishop takes King g5
threatening Knight g6 check blacks only
hope is stalemate but you can't give the
rook end of the ship away so there's no
stalemates man Caruana loves having two
connected passed pawns that's his
favorite thing I always hated having
that but now I starting to like it
Knight h3 is going to play Knight g5 9
h7 rook F 8 may yeah I was right
okay black doesn't want to get mated and
so he did the only thing he could do to
avoid me he resigned
well okay everything wins here but sure
the computer on it'll explode the
lecture will end still say like whites
up 33 or something so black can't move
white has a million ways to win putting
the rook on the seventh rank with Knight
f6 check threat playing g7 would win our
threatening rook f8 so that was a good
game
just like the Carlson game Cara wanna
advanced his majority eventually by
winning so many of blacks King side
pawns
he changed the majority from the Queen
side to the Kings side and that's called
trading advantages
sometimes your checkmating somebody and
they give a piece await and I get
checkmated and you don't take that piece
because you're trying to checkmate them
but if you chuck the piece you'd be a
piece out of the end game and win easily
so just because you have one advantage
sometimes you trade it for another one
and you can win just as easily White had
a passed pawn the C file but he took
many kingside pawns his majority
actually changes the kingside a to pawn
majority this can make she reminds me a
lot of the carlson game i got to flip
the board i think it's impossible okay
there we go alright this is a game you
played last year against your favorite
Russian player and Nipah machi and took
the bishop back now here we see some bad
pawn structures ok isolated pawns
doubled pawns horrible but actually
black has a big advantage here and
there's actually several advantages but
the most telling is this bishop on g2
that reminds me of the Mike comer Bishop
onceá that never gets out that bishop on
g2 it's not really going to participate
and this particular position
a4 is pretty weak but I don't see how
White's going to attack 85 so
potentially black's going to win upon
blacks also check in the night obviously
and that bishop on g2 never going to
take anything since the center is closed
and those pawns can't move the nice just
betters of the bishop so black has a
better minor piece and whites pawns are
actually weaker because White has more
weak pawns here we all have the same C
pawns and a pawns but we have an
isolated pawn on e4 here so black has so
many advantages he actually won pretty
easily
Queen e3 defending the knight and if I
take on a4 I can take on c5 that was a
good move Knight to f6 the Knights not
good on h7 right Meredith
Terrebonne h7 on the side horrible now
we're getting back into the center
Knight f3 Queen to d6 again black is in
no hurry black is defending his pawns
and he knows eventually he'll win the a4
or c4 pawn by maneuvering his Knights
around and the most important part of
the ending is white as no counter play
if I said what's White's plan
defending all of his bonds okay what is
y going to take can wine attack the
black king does black whatever majority
know so White's going to defend defend
defend and Caruana is in no hurry
91 Knight FA 93 attacking the pawn on c5
96 defending the pawn on c5 and now
White's sort of out of ideas now
and here comes black attacking all those
weak pawns c4 is attacked a4 is attacked
Knight B - just where you want your diet
now when I was at the super the super
when I was at the regular Nationals last
weekend in Tennessee I noticed whenever
you attack something the kids always
defend it in the most passive way
possible they're like yeah I didn't lose
a pawn and I'm like you just trapped
your piece for 40 moves so even though
white doesn't lose a pawn
that's a terrible night it defends two
pawns and there's no active play so
temporarily it's okay but in the long
run white doesn't have any plan you
don't want to have inactive pieces so if
I was white I would cheat and play
Knight to d5 because the cheating is the
in thing now
right we got feller just got reinstated
we got the guy in India we got you know
Boris lot even off come on cheater
cheating yeah cheating is the next
that's the way you do it okay yeah now
that Brady was fine approximately 1
million dollars I feel really bad for
him and also the Patriots let's have a
moment of silence I don't think the
Patriots can afford a million dollars I
don't so let's what a terrible
punishment okay alright so that night on
b2 is terrible
alright so Knight FA the Knights being
rerouted where I don't know probably f6
that's where I would go okay and he went
to f6 I was right for once
now the Knights attacking everything in
White's position is attacked and whites
defending
this should have three that defends
Queen d7 attacking the a for pawn again
Queen c2 so white defends everything but
it's just horrible the most passive
position ever 98 trying to go to d6 take
that c4 pawn and he did and white
defended okay and what what Lisa Simpson
say about the Bishop on d3 I hope you're
saying it at home anyone now she would
say a blockaded Bishop is of little
value and that Bishop is really
blockaded it can't do anything King f8
again Caruana is in no hurry
King e7 improving his King f6 is a good
move as I always say right Mike because
we have a pawn chain pawns are all
defended and why can't make any threats
he's just waiting to lose okay and now
black decides f5 is the winning idea
puts his king over safe on the King on
the Queen side and White's had enough
white knows if f5 comes his own king
might get open and the bishop on d3 is
defending e4 NC 4 so he finally cracks
under the pressure decides to get active
and see if he can get perpetual check or
trade enough pawns we have a question so
Queen f2 putting pressure on f6 and c5
and he takes one of the pawns check
Queen a1 threatening the pawn on c5 c3 I
should say putting White's King under
some pressure and also we're ready to
advance our pawn and make a queen now if
we look at the minor pieces the knight
on d6 looks pretty reasonable Bishop on
d3 not so much Cara Juana was very happy
to trade off the Knights leaving white
with this terrible piece
Queen d5 trying to get some checks in
and then f5 threatening Queen h1
checkmate with advantage so he takes
defending the mate plays c5 if you if
you take the pawn
I have several ways to win I can trade
Queens and then play Knight takes bishop
or I could check and take the bishop
with either piece so you didn't do that
c5 attacking the knight efore
threatening it's the same threat Queen
h1 me so I didn't want to get mated this
should take c4 I only see one when he
groove so I assumed he played it I only
see one winning move Mike that's what I
see I'll be played and we look silly
otherwise there we go and now blacks up
a piece and he has a meeting attack but
white ass or petulant Erie not even
trying to check him I would try I would
have played Queen da check and I would
have checked it at least four or five
times well three times two times yeah I
would have checked him twice check check
and then I would resign all right but
two checks is pretty good okay he played
queen d3 Knight takes e5 Knight b7
blacks up a piece white decided not to
resign for some reason she like
resigning is a good idea and a4 and now
he resigned I think no he didn't Wow
okay and here we resigned the game would
continue like this if he didn't resign
and most of you could win this position
with black most of you right possibly
all of you possibly
so I like that end game because Caruana
wasn't in a hurry his king was on the
kingside moved it to the Queen side and
then pushed his King side pawns and
White's position was too passive mainly
because the white square bishop was
terrible I thought sure ken was making a
lot of noise Erika okay and last but not
least again another Berlin this time
against Michael Adams and again unlike
the Carlsen Jim Adams actually has his
Queen side pawns amazing in the Carlson
game one of those pawns was missing so
white was a pawn ahead and here White's
going to win the same way he won against
Carlsen pushes King side pawns it used
to be well known the best Berlin player
in the world for black especially was
kramnik but now I think that that title
goes to Cara Juana he plays well with
white and black in the in the Berlin and
he has a lot of experience here just
like in the Carlson game the Knights on
d5 and white has a king side majority
unlike the Carlsen game black has a
queen side majority and the difference
is at some point black can play b5 but
white doesn't have to take it again very
patient and when b5 happens the Carlsen
game Caruana just took it and said you
have isolated pawns here the knight on
d5 needs to be protected so white only
has one reasonable move defending his c4
pawn b3 yeah he's like you can do
anything I'm going to defend that these
doubled pawns don't scare me they're not
going to be come past and I'm going to
push on the King side and get my past
pawn now the risk is if all the pawns
are traded sometimes when you win a
piece for your passed pawn you still
don't win and here will be like rook and
Knight against rook you wouldn't win so
if black can somehow trade all the pawn
he can still draw a three trying to get
counterplay he's hoping to win this pawn
later and have his own past pawn king e4
defends the night now the nice defended
about as many times as possible if this
was played in beginner breakdown I think
my camera would leave screaming he'd be
like why did you pin your own Knight
terrible but now the Knights super
defended and it was already pinned so by
having four pieces defend the night it's
pretty safe b4h for getting our majority
going Rick D - I like rook G - because
it defends the second rank so you're
never going to lose you're a pawn and it
also says to black what are you going to
do
Black is very passive because of the
fantastic center control by the knight
and the rook and I should say the King
okay
g5 okay now if black plays rook AJ to
win this a pawn Cara Juana has already
stopped that no counter play and that's
what he did anyway breaking the pin
stopping rook f1 check and whites
getting his majority going on the Kings
side takes the Queen side pawn and the
rest is very easy
I like Knight d5 again he's not being
greedy he just wants to stop counter
play he doesn't want his King to get in
trouble by these three pieces so he just
plays Knight d5 and says well your rook
can't get in there you can't do anything
I'm threatening this I'm threatening
this you're down two pawns and you can't
even check me takes takes might come or
approve trading with your head material
okay now this is the move Kappa blanket
would approve of advancing your majority
three against three on the Queen side
two against one on the King side f6
getting a queen is a good idea now in
this position Michael Adams played GF if
he plays rook takes g6 what would white
do
how does white crash through and make a
queen f7 threatening f8 and now black
has to give his rook away for the pass
bond Adams didn't like that so he played
G f king f5 defending his jeep on
attacking the F pawn and now most people
in the class would play king f7 g7 g8
and hope to win that black doesn't get
enough counter plan the Queen side but
actually it's better to Queen without
letting the guy sacrifice his work for
the pawn first g7 black doesn't want to
take yet he wants White's ways to tempo
and by the way I see this a lot
especially with the kids I'm teaching
when they're going to play g7 and King
f7 in similar positions a lot of times
they move their King first your king is
not the one that's promoting you got to
play g7 so the other work can't move
away somewhere so whenever your pawn is
advancing and your King is helping it
you always move the pawn first maybe
you'll Queen it without the guy doing
anything so King f7 would be a terrible
move g7 is much better not only is white
gonna play king f7 White's going to play
another move which blacks seem to forget
about or maybe you didn't matter
he played c5 and now we can Queen
without letting black sacrifice the rook
for the pawn somebody whispered it
pretty loud rook f5 check with the idea
of rook g5 then we're going to queen for
nothing in fact it would be a very
interesting game if white just played
King here and queen because then black
would get counter play also black would
sacrifice that's not clear at all that
White's winning but this is very clearly
White's winning Rick f5 check the King
moves Rev g5 we're going to be a queen
ahead after Rick
a five-car wanna drop the mic and left
so Adams was forced to resign game and
since car Wan is now going to play for
the u.s. another victory for the
colonies over Great Britain finally yeah
it took a long time and of course here
black resigned so in all those end games
we saw Cara Juana with pawn majorities
usually on the Kings side at the end
advancing them and using his king the
one big mistake a lot of people make in
the endgame is they don't move their
King up enough because in the opening
they know their king is supposed to stay
safe in the endgame your king is very
useful
you'd heat in with your king up and as
my commerce sudden beginner break down
when black had a king and a bishop he
said that bit was terrible worried about
the king the black king moves up that's
going to be good so why prevented that
in this game White's King moved forward
more forward defending the pawn on g7
and black had no chance
so if karma wanna really starts
improving his endgame like you see here
someday he might even the score against
me not he